>> THE KING.
WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SUNDAY
SHOW.
THE MIDTERMS DID NOT CHANGE THE
LEADERSHIP AT THE TOP.
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL.
HERE IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
THING STANK THE SAME.
AND ACCUSED DRUG DEALER BUSTED
WITH SET NO PILLS TWO DAYS AGO
IS REPORTEDLY ALREADY SET FREE.
>> MANY OF THE ISSUES WE WERE
CAMPAIGNING ON, THEY DO NOT JUST
GO AWAY A DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
WE HAVE TO WORK EVEN HARDER.
>> IN CALIFORNIA AT THE SHERIFF
IS FORCED TO STOP ALL DAYTIME
PATROLS DUE TO A STAFFING
SHORTAGE.
NOT ENOUGH COPS.
A VIOLENT CRIME RATE.
WE HAVE A FACEBOOK POST HERE
WHERE THE DEPUTY POINTED THE
FINGER.
WE HAVE SPOKEN TO THE BOARD FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND WARNED THEM
THAT STAFFING LEVELS ARE TOO
LOW.
RATHER THAN TAKE ACTION THEY
HAVE DELAYED AND ALLOWED TOO
MANY GOOD EMPLOYEES TO LEAVE.
TOM, I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST, 20
EMPLOYEES THIS YEAR.
TWENTY EMPLOYEES IS A LOT FOR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THEIR PAY RIGHT NOW IS 50-
50-62,000.
THE COUNTY NEXT DOOR IS 82,000
SPACE PAY.
SOME OF THIS IS MAY BE LESS
ABOUT WHAT THE POLITICS ARE MAB
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP.
>> THEY ARE.
YOU SEE IT HERE IN NEW YORK
CITY, A LOT OF OFFICERS ARE
SAYING I WILL GO TO FLORIDA
WHERE I HAVE A GOVERNOR THAT
SUPPORTS ME.
THAT IS A BIG PART OF THIS.
POLICIES THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT.
GETTING RID OF THIS NO CASH
THEY'LL AND THEN DOUBLE DOWN AND
IT.
ILLINOIS ABOUT TO SEE THE
FLOODGATES REALLY OPEN FOR THEM.
UPLIFTING OUR OFFICERS.
HAVE TO DO BETTER WORK AND
FIGHTING BACK SOME OF THIS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO UPLIFT OUR
OFFICERS AND MAKE THEM
UNDERSTAND HOW NEEDED AND
NECESSARY THEY ARE.
THEY DO NOT DO IT FOR THE MONEY
THEY DO IT BECAUSE IT IS A
HIGHER CALLING.
WHEN YOU DON'T GET THE SUPPORT
THAT YOU NEED, THAT IS A HUGE
DETERRENT FOR A LOT OF THOSE
WANTING TO ANSWER THAT CALL.
>> REPUBLICANS DID SUCH A GOOD
JOB IN CONNECTING COUNTY SCHOOL
BOARDS TO NATIONAL ISSUES.
HAVE WE MAY BE MISSED THE BOAT
HERE ON CONNECTING THESE LOCAL
ISSUES?
DAS TO NATIONAL ISSUES.
>> THAT IS ALWAYS THE MAGIC OF
POLITICS.
TAKEN ISSUE THE WAY IT WAS IN
PARENTAL CORE -- CONTROL.
REPUBLICANS FAILED TO DO AT THIS
TIME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BRIGHT
SPOTS, LEE ZELDON WHO DID NOT
WIN BUT CAME DARN CLOSE FOR VERY
BLUE STATE TALKED ABOUT CRIME
AND STAYED FOCUSED ON CRIME AND
PEOPLE FEEL THAT.
JD VANCE TALKED ABOUT THE
FENTANYL COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
MADE IT VERY LOCALIZED.
KEPT IT LOCAL BUT VERY DRAMATIC.
RON DESANTIS TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER.
THESE ISSUES, IF YOU CAN
LOCALIZE THEM AND PROSECUTE THE
CASE AS BRILLIANTLY AS THEY DID,
THAT IS HOW YOU WIN.
REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE ANOTHER
SHOT AT ALL OF THESE.
THESE ISSUES ARE NOT GETTING
BETTER ON THEIR OWN.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET WORSE.
NONE OF THIS PENT UP FRUSTRATION
WILL BE RELEASED, THIS TIME.
IT WILL BE RELEASED NEXT TIME.
>> THIS ISSUE WITH THE SHERIFFS
DEPARTMENT LOSING 20, IT MAY BE
AN ECONOMY ISSUE.
IF THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY
THESE GUYS AND GALS, MAYBE
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO THE COUNTY
OVER.
UNDER A STATE LAW, NOW ELIGIBLE
FOR BAIL AFTER A TWEAK THIS YEAR
TO THE ORIGINAL LAW.
THIS GUY IS OUT ON BAIL BECAUSE
OF WHAT DEMOCRATS DID IN NEW
YORK THIS YEAR.
LOOKING AT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
MIDTERMS AND WHAT DID
REPUBLICANS DO, THEY PUT THIS
BIG STAMP, CRIME IS AN ISSUE.
DID THEY DO A GOOD JOB AT
DEFINING HOW?
>> I ACTUALLY THINK LEE ZELDON
DID A GREAT JOB.
I SPOKE TO MANY WOMEN THAT VOTED
ON ABORTION.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT CRIME, I'M
WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION BUT I'M
WORRIED WOMEN'S RIGHTS
NATIONALLY WILL BE TAKEN AWAY.
IT WAS THAT FEAR MONITORING THAT
TURN THE BOAT HERE.
HE DEFINITELY DID SHINE THE
LIGHT ON WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE CASHLESS
BAIL, SHE WANTS TO IN THE
SUBWAY, FOR EXAMPLE, PUT MORE
CAMERAS.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE CASHLESS
BAIL AND YOU ARE NOT CHANGING
THE POLICIES IN THIS CITY, NONE
OF THOSE THINGS ARE DETERRENT
SPIRIT EVERYONE HAS iPhones
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF CAMERAS.
THAT IS PART OF THE ISSUE.
WITH THE OFFICERS, I ALSO THINK
IT IS A HUGE MORALE ISSUE HERE.
THEIR HANDS HAVE BEEN TIED
BEHIND THEIR BACK AND THEY FEEL
THEY ARE POWERLESS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE
FORCE IN DROVES BECAUSE THEY
JUST DO NOT WANT TO BE A PART OF
IT ANYMORE.
WE HAVE TO SUFFER NOW.
>> THE ONE ISSUE THAT ALL OF
THIS TOUCHES IS THE BORDER.
I JUST GO RIGHT BACK TO YOU ON
THIS, HOW IS IT THAT ALL OF
THESE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
PEOPLE'S LIVES ON THE PAROCHIAL
LEVEL ARE STILL CONNECTED TO
NATIONAL ISSUES AND YET THE
MESSAGING DOES NOT CONNECT.
>> I THINK THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
FAILED TO REFINE A FOCUSED
MESSAGE ON THAT ISSUE.
YOU KNOW, THE PROBLEM WITH THE
BORDER GOES BACK MANY DECADES.
YOU CAN BLAME DEMOCRATS --
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN MUCH
BETTER ABOUT THIS THAN DEMOCRATS
BOTH PARTIES FALL.
ALL PARTIES HAVE FAILED TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
IN 2016 WHEN DONALD TRUMP CAME
ALONG AND SAID THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE, BOTH PARTIES
FREAKED OUT AND SAID HE WAS
WRONG AND HE WAS RIGHT.
IN IS WHAT PEELED OFF DEMOCRAT
VOTERS.
>> ALSO IN TERMS OF MESSAGING.
IT WAS THE ONLY REPUBLICAN THAT
HAD A WINNING MESSAGE AT THE
BORDER, DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE IT
WAS SIMPLE.
FILLED THE WALL.
WE NEED MORE BATTLE CRIES LIKE
THAT.
DONALD TRUMP DID AT MASS FOR
EARLY.
>> BUILD THE WALL